when I was making my video about how you  can do the double slit experiment using  hair I actually saw the pattern turn up  quite a lot in a really unexpected  circumstance okay so here's my laser  right now while I look at the dot over  there I can see the double slip pattern  and you can't and the reason is because  my hair is falling in front of my eyes  let me show you why all right so now I'm  not going to put my hair in front of the  beam I'm just going to put it in front  of the camera  there is the double slip pen  some reason it's much clearer with my  eyes this laser that's  been scattering in ever in every  direction  coherently in every one of those  directions and so it's coherent light  that hits your eyes if you're going to  be doing experiments like this with  lasers then please please please buy  really good quality lasers that are safe  rather than like an Amazon laser because  that is going to burn your eyes out